our main story tonight concerns the news
media you know the people who announced
to the world that man had landed on the
moon World War two had ended and he'll
one day announced my tragic death after
a pelican swallows me whole look I love
corn dogs at the pier and taunting large
birds it's only a matter of time
chomp has made no secret of his disdain
for the media but he's also been holding
a lot of press conferences recently
which is highlighted the fact there is
one media outlet he seems to really
enjoy calling on okay couple of
questions go ahead Oh a n we'll take a
few questions
emerald Oh a n o n instinctively you
know that when Trump likes something
that much it's an immediate red flag
take this capybara with an orange on its
head it seems excellent but if Trump
were to repeatedly say I love that
capybara with an orange on his head you
just know we're about to find out all
the times that it wore black face in
college
Oh a n stands for one American news and
when you hear the kinds of questions
that they ask you begin to see why Trump
calls on them so much mr. president your
approval ratings have been the highest
they've ever been as well as the ratings
on your handling of the virus if there
are some networks that are saying
they're debating whether or not to carry
these briefings live do you think
there's a link between the two well I
don't know I know that well that's a
nice question thank you very much
what's that a nice question though I
guess it depends on what your definition
of one is if a nice question is meant to
extract any useful information at all
then it wasn't nice but if it's one that
makes the president feel happy for a
brief instant before that feeling like
all feelings is swallowed up by the
unfathomable avoid that yawns within him
always then yeah it was a very nice
question very nice indeed
and OAM has a lot of nice questions for
the president when he was criticized for
referring to the corona virus as the
Chinese virus one of their
correspondents rushed to his defense
with this beauty
term Chinese food racist knows it's food
that originates in China or it has time
no I don't think it's racist I don't
think it's racist at all
on that note major left-wing news media
even in this room have teamed up with
Chinese Communist Party narratives and
they are claiming you are racist for
making these claims about Chinese
pirates
it's an alarming that major media
players just oppose you are consistently
siding with foreign state propaganda
Islamic radicals and Latin gangs and
cartels and they work right here at the
White House with direct access to you
and your team Wow
it is pretty wild to watch the reactions
of the other journalists there who are
clearly not used to getting
from both sides of the room that is a
look that says how did I wind up in the
middle of this sandwich and it's
moments like that that explain why Trump
has such a love affair with Oh a n he
has repeatedly praised them on Twitter
at one point when he didn't like Shep
Smith's coverage of his administration
he tweeted that Shep Smith has the
lowest rated show on Fox News actually
whenever possible I turn to oen and his
family seemed like fans to just this
Thursday in the midst of a pandemic Oh a
and spent nearly 15 minutes chatting
with dong junior resulting in this
fantastic exchange are you binge
watching anything over there you gotta
go binge watching something yeah we
basically watched Tiger King in two
sittings for two grand
that should absolutely not be your
takeaway after watching that show
Tigers are surprisingly cheap also it
turns out you can hire a hitman for
$3,000 what a deal look Oh a n is a
relatively small organization but you
may well know someone who watches them
and they're punching way above their
weight right now and if they are in the
White House pressroom being called on
all the time and are more supportive for
the president than Fox we thought
tonight it may be worth taking a look at
who they are and what they do
owen is the brainchild of robert herring
conservative millionaire and son droids
Jake Gyllenhaal and since its birth Oh
Ian has been a home for extreme
conservatism how extreme well let's meet
their hosts for starters there's Graham
Ledger who's called blacklivesmatter a
criminal organization as called being
transgender a mental problem and set of
people coming to the u.s. from majority
Muslim countries if they won't take a
bite out of a pulled pork sandwich
we probably won't let them in the
country and it's wit like that that
makes him the null coward of meat
sandwich based race baiting he starts
every show with his signature
catchphrase the doors to the newsroom
are locked and the PC police are not
getting in and if that wasn't sweaty
enough he ends every show like this this
addition of the daily Ledger's I swear
the archives Library of Congress thank
you for watching I'm Graham ledger and
remember even when I'm wrong I'm right
yeah he signs off that way
every night and for the record we
actually asked the Library of Congress
whether the daily ledger is sent to its
archives and they told us and I quote
they have no record of the daily ledger
being submitted nor have we received the
shows as a collection and anyway getting
into the Library of Congress isn't
remotely impressive you know what's in
there
Jersey Shore is in there milf chronicles
for busty mansions is in there even our
show is in there it's true this is our
listing in their catalogue what I'm
saying is you wouldn't be keeping great
company even if you were in there which
you're not then of course this is
catchphrase even when I'm wrong I'm
right which is even stupider why would
you want to say something that implies
that you're both shamelessly partisan
and wrong and not in significant part of
the time it would make just as much
sense if his catchphrase was remember
even after I have explosive diarrhea I'm
still full of why would you admit
either of those things but it might
actually be good that led just specifies
his rightness even in wrongness because
he is wrong a lot and always with a
certain Ron Burgundy flair watch as he
tries to dismantle
saunders rhetoric unfettered capitalism
is what we should desire in this country
unfettered capitalism is what made this
country great in the industrial
revolution Carnegie and well the other
men that that built this country in the
late 1800s I'm blanking JP Morgan the
rest of them rockefeller there is a name
yeah there is a name
nice save Graham and that's the kind of
erudite historical insight that you can
find in his book the Industrial
Revolution how Andrew Carnegie and you
know the rest of them JP Morgan and
others the monopoly man maybe that's a
name built America through unfettered
capitalism
oh and Henry Ford but ledger isn't
the network's only bright lights you
already know shanell Rhian Oh a ins
White House reporter whose speciality
seems to be asking the questions that
are on absolutely no bodies Minds 2405
Americans have died from coronavirus in
the last 60 days yeah meanwhile you have
2369 children who are killed by their
mothers through elective abortions each
day that's sixteen and a half thousand
children killed every week okay that's
obviously a rhetorical bad fight
argument but what the hell let's engage
there are thousands of abortions and
thousands of coronavirus deaths that's
true we can disagree on whether those
things are equivalent they're not but if
only one of them is growing
exponentially every single day that
should probably be the one that we focus
on right the now but by all means
come back to that question once
abortions become involuntary and wildly
contagious now when Chanel Rhian isn't
asking nice questions in the White House
press room she also claims to be the
best political illustrator in the
country for constitutional conservative
and anti leftist causes which to be fair
is a very low bar to clear yet I'm not
sure if this drawing of Rachel Maddow as
wretched Mad Cow even manages to get
over it she also runs a word of the
a website called wert appease a world of
fine words featuring artful tributes to
floral language like Metanoia Orphic and
back Fife and kashish which apparently
means a face badly in need of punching
her about page explains that if we don't
nurture and grow our word realms we
don't nurture and grow our thought
realms and it's hard to know how to
describe a sentence like that thankfully
word Obie's has an entry on fanfare
innate which means empty self promoting
language and that seems to hit the nail
right on the head this website is so
handy then there is Liz wheeler who is a
big Trump favorite and she can develop
an argument just watch as over the
course of 54 seconds she spins an
aquarium's simple decision not to
announce the gender of a baby penguin
into something very different we should
ask where does radical leftist gender
ideology lead do liberals want human
children to be genderless if so why is
this based on biology and if not then
what what happens when human children
are raised genderless if gender is
destroyed doesn't that destroy
traditional gender roles and if gender
roles are destroyed doesn't that destroy
gendered relationships and if gendered
relationships are destroyed doesn't that
destroy traditional marriage and if
traditional marriage is destroyed
doesn't that destroy the family units
and if people aren't dependent on their
families then who do they depend on
that's right the government which is the
goal of liberals in the first place
don't let transgender penguins fool you
Wow
that argument is a walk I assume that
she uses that same chain argument logic
for everything ask yourself this
why do radical leftists want to expand
health insurance do liberals want
everyone to have health and if everyone
has health doesn't that mean no one will
ever die and if no one ever dies does
that mean Hitler would still be alive
and if Hitler is still alive isn't World
War two still happening and if World War
two is too
happening doesn't that mean our troops
are still fighting and if our troops are
still busy fighting in World War two
who's defending America from terrorists
that's right
no one which is the goal of liberals in
the first place don't let polyamorous
lobster's fool you and look it's not
just hard rights talking points the
network has actively given airtime to
conspiracy theories they put up a
$100,000 reward for information on Seth
Rich's murder last year they traveled
with Rudy Giuliani to Ukraine to shoot a
multi-part series featuring his
investigations there and just recently
Chanel Rihanna hosted a special in which
she boosted a conspiracy theory that the
coronavirus might have originated as a
bioweapon in a North Carolina laboratory
the whole selling point for OAM is that
they are Fox News with even less shame
and even fewer scruples in fact they're
so flagrantly smitten with Trump that at
one point their network account actually
tweeted president Trump recently gave a
speech thanking his supporters in the
media not a single mention of one
America news one of his greatest
supporters Oh a yen calls and
that is just pathetically thirsty they
shift from fawning praise to sullen fury
if people stop complimenting them for a
single second although when you put it
like that you do kind of get what I
weigh in and the president's seeing each
other and I know that it is easy to
dismiss away in as just a stupid little
watched borderline self-parody the
problem is if we're learning one thing
right now
it's that toxic things that start small
can get big fast and it's dangerous to
ignore them and right now the
president's putting a lot of energy into
boosting Oh a ends profile for instance
last week even as the number of
confirmed coronavirus cases in the u.s.
passed 65,000 Trump thought it was
important that his twitter followers see
this video guess what
thanks to you guys this book my book
it's number four on Amazon's bestseller
list in the political commentary
category thank you thanks
thank you so much yeah he retweeted that
with the notes by the book and give Liz
some great reviews which would
absolutely be weird enough even if Liz
wheeler hadn't posted that video last
August and we all know the rules here
liking someone's post is fine liking
someone's post from seven months ago is
the creepiest thing on earth and Trump
has had their back in other ways just
this week the White House Correspondents
Association actually revoked Owens
access to a seat in the briefings the
reason they did this was because most
reporters had agreed to take turns
attending to keep the room emptier and
follow social distancing rules but
chanel Ryan repeatedly showed up on
dates that she wasn't assigned a seat
yet despite having her seat revoked on
Wednesday Rihanna was back in that room
the very next day telling people that
she'd been personally invited as a guest
of the White House press secretary and
that is a problem because in the best of
times you can laugh at an almost
anchorman esque parody of right-wing
news but much like the problem with
anchorman - it's just not the right time
for Ron burgandy right now o Am's weird
combination of far-right wing talking
points and dirt stupid reporting is
incredibly dangerous at a time like this
Graham ledger has explicitly called for
Americans to defy the government's
advice on social distancing and has
justified his argument like this I would
rather die of coronavirus a free person
then live like a slave to government
engulfed in fear panic and with no
Liberty this addition of the daily
ledger is on its way the archives
Library of Congress thank you for
watching I'm Graham ledger and remember
even when I'm wrong I'm right honestly
has monumentally dumb as that
catchphrase is it still might be too
smart for Graham ledger he deserves a
catchphrase more on his intellectual
level maybe something like on Graham
ledger and remember anything can be food
if you eat it and incidentally that is
just the tain TV version of Graham
ledger online he's even worse just watch
a video that he posted on Tuesday
this week in which he claimed that it
was important that he get his hair cut
and framed it as a brave act of civil
disobedience do you know what we have to
do because we're living under and edict
not unlike Hitler's Germany or Joseph
Stalin in the Soviet Union we're living
under tyranny instead of Liberty we have
to do this in clandestine style my
hairdresser could be fined and or
arrested for what she's doing this is
not unlike of course what they had to
live through during Hitler's time okay a
couple of things there first of all it's
not essential that you get your hair cut
people on TV don't always look
well-groomed trust me trust me Hey look
at me trust me second Hitler didn't
outlaw haircuts he was a fascist about
personal grooming other stuff too but
mainly that and third if we were living
under a Nazi occupation maybe don't film
yourself on roots to your secret
underground resistance along which it
took literally five minutes on Google to
figure out is presumably somewhere
around the moon like Plaza shopping
center in Encinitas California and look
the problem here is the kind of
misinformation owain is spewing right
now could end up getting people killed
and sadly their message is being
actively spread by the White House so it
is more important than ever to be on the
lookout for Oh Ann's and to
make sure no one that you know is
falling forward either and I know that
just calling it may seem crude
so for all of those of you who might
desire a more eloquent plea let me offer
some language from Chanel RIANZ web site
were derbies in this Vespertine hour I
implore you to ignore a news network
that attempts to Glos this
administration's ineptitude during a
pandemic whether it be a scientist like
Liz wheeler a back Fife and kashish like
Graham Ledger or a rake fire like Chanel
Rihanna for these people are not just
irresponsible my friends there are a
bunch of FOP doodles that is our
show thank you so much for watching we
will see you next week I'm John Oliver
and this edition
last week tonight is for some reason
actually on its way to the Library of
Congress
don't let bicurious manatees fool you
good night
you